DDP is the real deal I think Robert
Whittaker you know you look at his
fights before this he looked pretty
good he can't say this is an
older version Robert Whittaker I think
Drake is duplis is that good
it's time we started acknowledge it does
he look like it is he no does he look
like a Wonder Boy God no does he look
like uh you know Tyson Fury when it
comes to boxing does he does he have the
kicks of uh Yaya Rodriguez no man does
he look like Alex volkanovsky or you
know even Brad Moreno with his boxing
God no what he looks like is Enriquez
duplicis that we've never seen and it's
good and it's damn near
impossible to beat and it's you know I'd
love to talk to his coach
you know hats off to them they've done a
great job with him in in tuning his
style and getting it to this world-class
level that and nobody believed in him
nobody but his coaches and probably his
few family members thought he was going
to be at this level